“The calm before the storm.”
As a metaphor, it normally means a lull that
occurs just before a huge and often catastrophic
event takes place.
However, there is such a thing as a literal
calm before a storm.
The saying comes from a weather phenomenon
where a tranquil period of stillness and serenity
takes place, only for the winds to start picking
up, the rain to start falling, and the storm
to suddenly begin to hammer down.
Nobody likes being caught outside when a thunderstorm
rolls into town, but thunder isn’t always
the worst part of a storm.
That sudden and unsettling flash of lightning
that unpredictably cracks across a dark sky
- the electricity - erratic and volatile in
behavior - might just be the part that startles
you into wishing - hoping - praying to return
to the calm before the storm.
SCP-938 is an entity composed of sheer electrical
energy.
Forget the notion of a simple dynamic current
with an unassuming physical form, and imagine
more - a creature composed of pure relentless
electricity.
Far from just a benign and passive phenomenon,
SCP-938 is considered a formidable and menacing
predator by the SCP Foundation.
What kind of prey could a being made out of
electricity be interested in hunting?
Well, that’s easy: power grids.
During moderate electrical storms, SCP-938
will appear, traveling through the static
electricity carried by such storms.
Lightning strikes are a form of static electricity,
and when they are expelled, SCP-938 uses these
strikes to attack its prey.
So, picture it, a stormy night, the rumble
of thunder overhead.
Every booming sound is accompanied by a bright
flash, maybe even a forked strike of lightning
that appears for a brief second.
And carried within that lightning is SCP-938,
hurling through the sky towards its target:
the nearest electrical grid.
Now, at this time, it is unknown whether or
not SCP-938 actually actively causes electrical
storms to occur.
Research into the weather patterns in the
areas the entity has appeared has proven inconclusive,
and there is no proof that this power-based
predator is able to influence the weather.
However, the second that SCP-938, as a lightning
strike, makes contact with the nearest power
grid, the surrounding area normally suffers
a complete loss of all power.
Street lamps will go out, plunging the entire
city or town into total darkness.
This doesn’t last forever though, as you
might expect.
You see, this creature has the potential energy
of a storm, much like the ones it uses to
travel.
SCP-938 isn’t out to absorb more energy
from national or local power grids - or at
least, certainly not all at once.
What the entity actually does is the following.
After the brief loss of power, SCP-938 will
quietly infiltrate an electrical grid that
provides energy to a town, city, state, or
even an entire country.
From within, the entity then chooses a structure,
seemingly at random, to monitor.
These are usually occupied buildings like
homes, offices, or apartment complexes, with
plenty of people inside.
And no, it doesn’t then delight in turning
on its charge and frying all those inhabitants,
transforming the building into a giant bug
zapper.
But the more people in a structure, the more
electrical appliances and devices you’re
likely to find inside.
SCP-938 stays dormant for a while, hiding
out in the power grid and is usually only
detectable by special equipment designed to
monitor electromagnetic fields.
However, the next time a storm comes a-rolling
into town, the living electrical energy wakes
up and begins to cause havoc.
The easiest-to-spot indicator of this is that
SCP-938 will normally begin interfering with
any electrical devices in the structure it
has chosen.
Its goal is to cause enough disruption that
it draws the attention of the inhabitants
living there.
People inside this building will quickly realize
that their appliances aren’t working as
they should be, sparking and malfunctioning
to an alarming degree.
These devices will then even cause severe
electrocutions to any who come into direct
physical contact with them.
In every case, this increased electrical activity
has caused the neural impulses of anyone in
the chosen building to be shut down, resulting
in death.
There are only two instances where this didn’t
happen.
In 1987, during an incursion with SCP-938,
two victims had their hearts stopped after
being electrocuted by devices affected by
the entity.
Fortunately, these two individuals survived
after being successfully resuscitated but
suffered long-term psychological damage as
a result of the incident.
Both were noted to have lost significant portions
of their memories and even had their mannerisms
and personalities dramatically altered.
After a storm, SCP-938 will return to the
atmosphere, once again in the form of a lightning
strike, and free from the power grid it was
previously hiding in.
From that point, the entity will aim to repeat
the process all over again, in a new location,
fixating on a new building and claiming the
lives of more innocent civilians.
However, this is not a set-in-stone pattern
of behavior for SCP-938.
Analysis of the electromagnetic field readings
taken in the creature’s vicinity show that
it is at least somewhat capable of the same
level of conscious thought as most human beings,
displaying similar electrical fluctuations
to the neural activity of a human brain.
Perhaps it is through this disembodied capacity
for thought that SCP-938 occasionally chooses
a specific person to pursue.
Although it is unclear what criteria the electrical
entity looks for in a target, the creature
has been known to fixate on a single individual
and track them for an extended period of time.
In one instance, SCP-938 pursued a target
for thirty-six years, eleven months, and six
days until that person died of natural causes.
These targets, designated as SCP-938-A, will
experience symptoms similar to those suffered
by individuals suffering from various stress
or paranoia-related psychological disorders.
This includes the rapid onset of conditions
like post-traumatic stress disorder and paranoid
schizophrenia.
SCP-938-A instances will also quickly develop
severe phobias, even if they have never exhibited
these previously.
However, these aren’t what SCP-938 looks
for in a victim, instead these disorders and
conditions seem to be directly caused by the
influence of the entity itself.
But the side effects of being in the vicinity
of SCP-938 don’t stop there.
In fact, some of the SCP Foundation’s own
personnel have even been affected.
According to several members of Theta 9, a
Mobile Task Force codenamed ‘Bad Moon Rising’,
being close enough to the entity can trigger
subtle yet unsettling hallucinations.
The most common of these is the sight of a
cluster of eyes that glow with iridescent
colors, meaning they appear to change shade
when viewed from different angles.
Reportedly appearing in poorly lit areas,
these eyes seem to watch a person that is
suffering from this hallucination.
The iridescent eyes have been seen in the
shadows of other people, as well as appearing
in dense foliage like bushes or hedgerows.
Even after the Foundation was able to successfully
contain SCP-938, staff reported that these
hallucinations still continued to persist.
But while on the topic of containment, you’re
probably wondering: How does the SCP Foundation
manage to keep a being of pure electricity
secure?
Well, with great difficulty is the short answer.
They actually spent almost half a century
trying to contain SCP-938.
Why did it take them so long?
In part, that was down to the wildly unpredictable
nature of SCP-938 and how it moves using electrical
storms.
Sure, predicting exactly when and where a
storm is going to hit isn’t impossible,
just tricky to achieve with pinpoint accuracy
- especially if you’re deciding in advance
which day to go to the beach or have a picnic
in the park.
But even if you knew beforehand that a storm
was on its way to an area, there is no indicator
that SCP-938 would be coming with it.
They’re squirrely little anomalies like
that.
Another factor preventing the Foundation from
containing SCP-938 was a simple case of poor
timing.
When they first encountered the entity, it
was still 1943; A time when they didn’t
even have close to the sufficient technological
advancement required to track and contain
the creature.
The entity was, after all, made from a tremendous
amount of electrical energy, more than could
be safely stored in any one device or location
with the tech available in 1943.
All the Foundation could hope to do was mitigate
the threat that SCP-938 posed, focusing on
trying to predict its movement and behavior.
For a while, containment just seemed like
it wasn’t an option.
Six years later, the first instance of SCP-938-A
appeared.
This was the person that we mentioned earlier,
who the electric energy entity followed for
almost thirty-seven years.
In this case, the Foundation’s security
personnel were able to get to SCP-938-A first,
and kept them out of the grasp of the predatory,
power-based creature.
These security forces soon became part of
Mobile Task Force Theta 9, and they took charge
of ensuring SCP-938-A remained safe.
And for a while, they achieved this, until
the target died of a heart attack in 1986.
You already know that part, but what you don’t
know is that ten minutes before the target’s
death, an ambulance arrived at the Foundation’s
safe house.
No member of Bad Moon Rising had called the
emergency services, and the local dispatch
center hadn’t even received a call for assistance
to that safe house.
The emergency dispatcher on duty that night
had spotted an unanswered request for an ambulance
on his computer terminal.
It’s almost as if something had interfered
with the machine, in order to lure the ambulance
into responding to SCP-938-A.
This is what prompted the Foundation to once
again consider the possibility of containing
SCP-938.
They knew it would be an expensive endeavor,
this was 1989 after all, but as soon as a
possible new SCP-938-A target had been identified,
the Foundation had the perfect bait to catch
the creature that had eluded them since the
1940s.
Luring it in with its new target, SCP-938
was successfully captured and contained within
a Capacitor Bank at a Foundation research
site.
A Capacitor Bank is a series of electrical
capacitors, joined and kept parallel with
each other, for the purposes of storing electrical
energy.
Think of it as a big battery, except there
is a key difference between the two.
While batteries store electrical energy as
some form of chemical energy like lithium,
a capacitor is, in basic terms, designed to
store pure electrical energy.
Exactly like what SCP-938 is made from.
Containment wasn’t without its teething
problems, however, and SCP-938 almost made
an escape in 1991.
Bio-Containment and Research Site 06 suffered
a ‘Silent Night’ breach scenario, and
SCP-938 was able to cause considerable damage
to the site’s infrastructure.
The building itself was left completely unsalvageable,
and the Capacitor Bank for storing the entity
had to be rebuilt before SCP-938 was recaptured.
The new Capacitor Bank was moved to Bio-Containment
and Research Site 07, and kept in a fully
electrically insulated storage warehouse.
The entire structure was built to have no
wiring or electrical systems of any kind,
with no metal supports in the concrete it
was constructed from.
Even staff with pacemakers or metal prosthetics
aren’t allowed inside.
There is nothing conductive, nothing metal,
nothing electrical: in short, there is no
way SCP-938 could ever escape again.
Hopefully, at least, just as long as no one
brings anything electronic into Storage Warehouse
Zero.
Unfortunately, on December 21st 2005, a Foundation
doctor entered the warehouse as part of a
routine inspection of the creature’s ongoing
containment.
What this doctor had clumsily forgotten was
that he had been carrying a USB flash drive
on his person, and didn’t realize his mistake
until the next day.
After he recognized his error, he submitted
the memory stick for examination, only to
find that everything stored on it had been
wiped, replaced with indecipherable, meaningless
data.
All we can really do is just hope that data
is all that was on that flash drive.
After all, surely SCP-938 wasn’t able to
breach its containment again, and escape hidden
on a USB stick, right?
Perhaps it’s best to play it safe, just
in case.
Next time there’s a thunderstorm in your
town, maybe leave home and go for a drive
somewhere far away for a while.
The last thing you’d want is something lurking
throughout the wires in your house, waiting
and ready to strike.
Now go check out “SCP-3999 - I Am At The
Center of Everything That Happens To Me”
and “SCP-5031 - Yet Another Murder Monster”
for more mysterious anomalous entities from
the SCP Foundation!